more confusion and arrogance at the
white house
i've seen more
of dr fauci that i have my wife we kid
each other but
they look who's president fouchy
but all kidding aside i sincerely mean
it
yes who is president joe biden joking
this week that dr anthony fauci is the
real president as the
commander-in-chief's poll numbers
plummet again to new lows and red states
like florida and texas show the lowest
number of covent infections and some of
the highest investment dollars anywhere
joining me right now is the governor of
the great state of texas greg abbott is
here governor thanks very much for being
here congrats to you on a lot of good
news i want to get to your investments
from tesla and samsung in a moment but
first tell us about the omicron variant
what has it meant for texas where are
you on the coveted infections
so for one because uh you know you
talked about how we have a low rate of
infections compared to so many other
states and one reason uh that we've been
able to achieve that is because we've
been open uh a hundred percent uh there
are no vaccine mandates or mass mandates
and so it shows uh that we can remain
open and help livelihoods while also
making sure that we do a good job of
protecting lives now as it concerns the
new variant we're being very aggressive
and trying to address it
the department of state health services
is working with local health care
providers across the entire state to be
able to
test samples of cova-positive cases to
determine whether or not they do contain
the new variant we're working to make
sure that vaccines are available to
anybody who wants a vaccine and also
working to make sure that we make it
easier for people to get a test so they
can determine whether or not they may
have the new variant or just have the
delta whatever the case may be but also
we uh in anticipation of a potential
increase in hospitalizations uh we're
working to
uh surge more nursing and medical
personnel to make sure that our
hospitals will be able to deal with it
well it's pretty extraordinary when you
look at what's going on in europe right
now governor you've got lockdowns in
austria germany locking down
unvaccinated people what are your
thoughts because the white house has not
ruled out a vaccine mandate for domestic
travelers we're waiting to see where
this omicron story goes next
well i can tell you in texas we are
ruling out vaccine mandates we're ruling
out lockdowns there's no need for things
like that
texans know exactly what they need to do
in order to protect themselves and they
don't need government telling them what
to do and i think the same thing should
apply from the white house
so texas is open and thriving and you
have had a multiple number of victories
this week alone a federal judge blocking
joe biden from enforcing the two
mandates requiring millions of workers
to get vaccinated your executive order
banning mask mandates by government
entities becomes law tell me about the
economic story in texas i know that
tesla announced it's officially moving
its headquarters from silicon valley to
austin what does that mean for texas and
then there's samsung committing to a 17
billion dollar semiconductor factory in
taylor texas this is going to be
real impactful not just for texas but
for the country as we battle this
shortage of semiconductor chips
well it's huge i'll address both issues
that you raise and that is first
texas has been very aggressive about
legally challenging all of these
mandates that the body administration
has put in place concerning covet
whether it be vaccine mandates or mass
mandates whatever the case may be
and we've been winning them all in the
course and right now in texas there are
no federal mandates that apply the only
mandate that applies
is my executive order saying that nobody
in the state of texas can be mandated to
take a vaccine shot obviously they're
available for anybody who wants it but
there can be no mandates infringing upon
individual liberty
that is in part why i think there are so
many businesses that are moving to the
state of texas maria over
just the first 11 months of this year
there have been 70 businesses and
corporations that have relocated their
headquarters to the state of texas if
you look on average that means there's a
new headquarters in texas every five
days one of those as you mentioned is
tesla that first announced their
gigafactory here in the state and then
they announced their headquarter move
you mentioned samsung semiconductor a 17
billion dollar investment in taylor
texas which is just outside of austin
where they will be building additional
semiconductors that is in addition to an
announcement the week before where texas
instruments announced a 30 billion
dollar investment for semiconductors
those semiconductors will help in the
supply chain process but the state of
texas economy is growing and thriving in
their businesses they're moving here
that are growing here because texas is
the land of economic opportunity and
innovation
well this is a huge story and this is
going to have impact throughout the
country we know right now the dominance
of taiwan on semiconductors one other
reason that china wants to
go in acquire taiwan so that they could
be in charge of all semiconductors this
is going to alleviate the semiconductor
problem and shortage that america is
facing so that's that's just great news
for texas do you expect more what's what
are you expecting in terms of more
investment coming down the road any any
vision or runway for us
sure we got actually a lot of positive
uh projects that are coming our way but
listen you touched upon something that's
very important and that is a lesson that
americans have learned and by god uh the
by administration uh should learn this
also uh and that is the country made a
mistake over the past one or two decades
to farm out manufacturing of all these
essential supplies whether it be now
semiconductors or it could be healthcare
supplies that we needed during the time
of covet whatever the case may be
we need to not depend upon china or
other countries for our essential needs
for things like semiconductors and that
is exactly why texas actually is leading
the way of becoming the home for
semiconductors that go into everything
that people use it's not just your
iphone or your laptop or whatever the
case may be it's also in in all of these
vehicles uh we have manufacturing going
on uh in fact just this last week we we
announced uh the rollout of the new
toyota tundra and they use these
semiconductor chips in their trucks and
so
texas will be the home of semiconductor
manufacturing going forward
all the more impressive given what you
are facing in terms of the challenge at
the border so because of the omicron
variant joe biden came out this week and
put new mask restrictions uh mask
mandates rather in place until march of
2022 and he was asked about covet
testing given the fact that now
travelers coming into the united states
are required to test for covid within 24
hours here's dr fauci answering the
question from fox news star peter ducey
about testing covid at the border watch
this
anybody and everybody who's coming into
the country needs to get a test within
24 hours of getting on the plane to come
here well what about people who don't
take a plane and just these border
crossers coming in in huge numbers
that's a different issue for example
when you're talking we still have title
42 with regard to protection at the
border so there are protections at the
border that you don't have the
capability as you know of somebody
getting on a plane getting checked
looking at a passport we don't have that
there
governor set the record straight for us
who's not getting tested at the border
and also we do have breaking news this
morning we have the latest unofficial
border numbers from our border sources
for the month of november and it is
getting worse we had 168
000 apprehensions for the month and 52
429 got aways in other words those
people came into the country they were
seen on surveillance cameras they got
away we are looking at 600 000 godaways
this fiscal year up 40 percent your
thoughts on testing for covid and all of
this impact of the wide open border in
texas
maria i'm i'm unaware whether or not dr
fauci has ever actually been to the
border certainly during the time of
covid i don't think he has any personal
uh first-hand knowledge whether or not
people are being tested coming across
the border i however
am on the border either every week or
every other week and i've been dealing
with and talking to border patrol as
well as the texas national guard and the
texas department of public safety who
are apprehending these people coming
across the border and what i can tell
you for a fact is most of the people
coming across the border if not all of
them
are not being tested the point is this
the president and the byte
administration uh they have two
standards if you're going to pay money
to come into the united states of
america lawfully you have to be tested
however if you come into the country
illegally you don't have to be tested
and as you know the numbers uh there
have been more than a million people
who've come across the border illegally
that we know of uh this year
most of whom have not been tested and so
the bi-administration actually has no
adequate information to determine the
extent to which people are coming across
the border by the millions
to know whether or not they are bringing
covid or the omicron variant whatever
the case may be into the united states
of america that is completely
irresponsible and extremely dangerous
you talked about
absolutely the guttaways and and the
reason why we have got aways is because
the body administration has tied the
hands of both the border patrol as well
as ice they have insufficient number of
personnel on the border to secure the
border and that's exactly why texas has
10 000 national guard and texas
department of public safety officers on
the border that's why we are erecting
these barriers on the border and it's
exactly why texas is building its own
border wall
which
exactly and one of my sources told me
about the lawlessness happening in in
houston he told me there are 400 000 new
people in houston right now because
there are getaway cars picking them up
from the border driving them to houston
in fact i was told one of the biggest
businesses in houston right now is
producing fake documents that these
companies that produce fake documents
for these illegals are just soaring
what's going on in houston and by the
way a federal judge is insisting that
the biden administration re-implement
remain in mexico but my sources on the
ground said i'll believe it when i see
it they still think they're going to
blow off the law your thoughts on what's
going on in houston as well as this
remaining mexico policy real quick sir
so the remaining mexico that was the
result of a lawsuit brought by texas
against the body administration where a
federal judge ruled in our favor
compelling the body administration to
reinstate the remaining mexico policy of
course we are apprehensive about the
extent to which the administration will
reimpose it however the news reports are
that they are going to begin doing it i
think they have gotten
agreement by the mexican government to
begin that process beginning this
weekend in early next week but of course
as usual we'll believe it when we see it
with regard to these uh crimes that
you're talking about taking place
listen this is part of cartel activity
the cartels are advertising on tick-tock
to get drivers to assist in them moving
illegal immigrants around the state of
texas it's an issue that the texas
department of public safety is working
to crack down upon but it shows the
extent to which texas law enforcement
officers have to step up and deal with
the challenges that are created by the
by demonstration importing illegal
activity into our country and into our
state
all right we will leave it there
governor thanks very much for your
leadership good to talk with you this
morning
we have reported on the tick tock angle
as well thank you sir